[Background voices]
YURI LANE >> Hello. My name is dwat-dwer-Yuri
Lane-bbbd-bbbt-tssp-sshk-tssp-sshk-dowwa Human
Beatbox. And-uh-uh-the question that's been
going around is how would I make a world a
better place. Dwoh! Well, number one, every
human being should have access to drinking
water-bwoop!
They should be able to grow their own food
and freedom of movement. We are-we take for
granted that we can go anywhere. I'm an American
citizen--I know, I know. I can go pretty much
anywhere. So I think that if you have the
opportunity to travel and to see other people
and to experience how other human beings live
in other parts of the world, I think that
can bring people together.
But me being an artist, I think everyone should
be able to put something out there through
art. SO my art is pfft-ppp beatbox. And every
character has their own soundtrack. So maybe-ah-Bill
Gates has a song in his head. So he should
get that song and bring it out with the ppsss-ppssh-pppt
the beatbox.
So if we can exist and learn about each other
through sound. Because everyone has a sound
they can make. So maybe we don't have to speak
a language. We'll speak a language that is
just: bzzzt-ppmph-p-p-mmm-p-p-mmm-p-p-mmm
music because music is universal and everyone
understands that language. So that is my take
to make a world psst-pssh-pp a better place.
Pkeooww...